[Music]
in feeding for thrills news o submitted
by Joe has no toenails I don't that's
what they say I have it that's what they
said my friend alright it's true that
unless you want to clear up the rumor I
think it's over [ __ ] beautiful
toenails [ __ ] well you can't see it on
a screen
not your pink your toenail yeah you're
painting that's pretty pretty small
everybody but it's still there a
suburban mom blames boredom for her
crime spree I believe it I believe it
too yep oh you had me at suburban mom
yeah I think like rich people get bored
and like they do like really crazy
things like the purge drugs and they do
like yeah oh I thought they just go
shopping or something all the rich kids
I knew growing up we're the most likely
to do the burgle or to its to burgle
look it up look it up 100k to do drugs
all that stuff those rich kids are boys
look it up welcome back thank you you
were never on my back actually at my
back to the whole time the silly way to
say it Rob frugal I like burgle
I like burgle - I like it - is just
silly your glasses are silly on top of
your head they're not mine they're Zoe's
[ __ ] I got burned
it's burglarizing burglarizing that
sounds [ __ ] that doesn't matter
I think it's burgled okay Star Trek all
right Hamburglar Rising Star Trek woman
she's a mother of two [ __ ] her name's
Melissa 30 years old I just say Hawaii
woman oh hi Ohio Illinois Hawaii the
Iowan Ohio mix so yeah Melissa here
apparently she said that she got a
packet her neighbors package came to her
her home she got a taste of blood
and stirred when she was just like well
no don't return it to my neighbor's so
she walked over to her neighbor's house
to return this package and she noticed
if there were other packages there just
sitting there so she was like well he
doesn't want it then I'm gonna keep it
so she kept it what already didn't just
come home yet I love that logic it's
1:13 he doesn't want right on my name
you didn't probably see the cars in the
driveway here's the one I'll take them
all Savannah by the way she acts like a
suburban housewife oh damn she's bored
she's aboard ladies she looks like
she'll some cowboy boots just like a
square dancer users Janet yeah what
military branch
oh yeah which military is wearing the
wrong sheet of lipsticks for veteran in
space force space horse chair force no
anyway it's just she's saying that uh
she had it all she just been very bored
that she she apparently did a tour
enough Afghanistan but man I'm used to
shooting [ __ ]
his wife [ __ ] is boring I need a spiel
so that's why she when she took that
cutting edge that first package she felt
this thrill and like she just got
addicted to it she joined the fire gank
like normal veterans I gotta say that
the stealing packages thing is just so
unsexy sounding yeah like a like going
into like a Saks Fifth Avenue like
Winona Ryder ring yeah [ __ ] but get
seems sexy as [ __ ] like there's people
there that catch you what's the charge
right but packages is like people aren't
home you're just picking up off a porch
easily see and then a lot of people have
security cameras you guys by the dog yep
the Dodger sprinklers
our [ __ ] it's not sexy it's like
stealing [ __ ] houseplants like on the
porch oh hey like house pants are cool
yeah but package and my heart was racing
cuz I'm like dude I hope they don't
think I stole this [ __ ] they just mailed
it to me and I just rang the door and I
like ran I would never think that you
ran you didn't wait for the milk no I'm
just like I don't want to have a human
interaction wouldn't you what do you do
with the package I get sent to your
place but the that person no longer
lives there and then you don't know
where the [ __ ] they live I just open it
or I throw it away okay we let a package
sit for like two months in our house I
feel much better cuz I was like I don't
know where to send this and it's been
two months
oh you're just supposed to put I'll
return to sender I thought about
remember Elvis we're done descend Oh
great song great song remember blue
suede shoes do it do it you already did
it I can't pop that yeah you guys Elvis
fanatics over here okay we just want to
take this video in an Elvis direction
you guys don't seem to ever see Elvis
literally that's what I think that's how
I nude its do return to sender because
of all this so Alvis save that person's
package you ever heard that song return
to sender address unknown no such number
no such home I just thought since it was
through Amazon if they never brought
their package they'd just be like I
never got my package and then I get sent
to another one
did you ever open it well so I asked Eve
first because I was like I have a more
an ethics question for you awesome that
you asked should we or shouldn't we we
have an appointment I felt like it was
gonna be bad juju if we opened it in our
place like oh you know it's not it's not
ours
no it's kind of like stealing yeah Wow
but what was tight cuz we open it and
there was a Canon 60d inside yeah two
thousand dollar camera with camera no it
was a shitty [ __ ] it was a she
to the blacktop cover that didn't even
fit our laptops you know I recently got
a package for my neighbor but I never
looked I mean I don't look at the sign
or the label well I mean it's in my
patio it's mine right so I just opened
it oh you don't know I don't
Oh looks like oh it's our port kasey
kahne if you don't normally get a
package from someone else like any one
more king she doesn't get to experience
the joy of opening a package cuz he'll
leave his package is there forever and I
have to open it for Holi so anyway so
then I opened and I realized I wasn't
something I ordered so then I looked at
them big it was so weird cuz the
apartment number that we're in it's like
so far away from the apartment number
that it belonged to so I'm like this
person was just lazy as [ __ ] there's
like [ __ ] it they'll return it to the
media
yeah they used to happen at our old
apartment all the times they would go to
the building next to us and drop it at
101 cuz we lived in apartment 101 and
they would go with building across the
street and drop it at 101 so the guy
from over there [ __ ] them used to it
yeah man
damn cuz Nikki gets back use every
single day let me know about that yeah
[ __ ] spilling ass girl
so then so she ended up stealing 28
packages or stealing packages from 28
palaces over the course of two days no
wicked children in the car you guys feel
happy huh yeah there's like two more
this reminds me of the army apparently
back in 2010 she was sentenced to three
years in prison for larceny after
stealing from a store and then spring
mace at workers who tried to stop her is
this post army yeah you can't really go
yeah cuz you can't go in the military if
you have a record later no and then she
was arrested in November 2 after she
slept with a man who is not her husband
she cheated on her husband stole this
man's credit card went to Walmart at 3
a.m. bought a whole bunch of [ __ ] and
she also booked a family vacation during
that time and then she went
[Music]
and then return his stolen credit card
she sounds like the perfect CIA recruit
but did she booked a family vacation
with the guys stolen credit card
yeah she's dumb as [ __ ] how was she so
stupid
but she's caring Wow she looks different
there even though even though she's
being selfish and she's getting dick and
doing whatever she's still thinking
about her family and thinking I need to
do something special oh we should girl
yeah we should go to sandals yeah I'm
gonna go I'm gonna take up to Orlando
Florida to go go-karting oh that's fine
she made it a point to uh to say she
lives in a four hundred and seventy five
thousand dollar house and this is in
Ohio so it's a [ __ ] mansion house um
lucky and so she's like I have it all
like I'm just really bored because she
ended up posting a Facebook post on her
neighborhood Facebook and she was just
apologizing and everyone she stole from
and saying like I'm so disgusted with
myself I don't know okay I'm the worst
person I've cheated on my husband I've
done this before
I'll do it again with my kid now I'm a
good person I love it yeah cuz this
isn't the first time mm-hmm
he's like is the first time I stole but
before that I did credit card fraud
[ __ ] hundred three difference maybe she
just likes it nay she likes pain her
husband here like she's into words this
guy you know been like there's no
mention of and there's Julie got married
she should have just stayed army CIA
[ __ ] you know like a super spy sex
pots she would have been perfect for
that [ __ ] yeah she's attractive
maybe she blames love she's like I
should have never fallen in love
yeah I'm sure never hey kids maybe maybe
having kids was her mistake like what
aunt told us today
[Laughter]
save it how do you save it Steve why do
you save it I know he's just kidding
I am kidding
no I mean I I remember when I was a kid
I stole from my neighbor I was at his
house and I was like 5 years old and he
had this little the little mermaid
flounder like things that we put it in
the sea in it yeah it's course water
yeah [ __ ] put it on my pocket oh so
tight and then and I didn't really think
about it how old are you no no I was
guilty about it but I wasn't like oh
this is like the most scary thing
because what happened next
so I get home and I'm playing with it
and my mom's like where did you get that
Steven and I might oh god oh god right
the that jammies please and she's like
that is not yours he doesn't belong to
you and so she made me throw with your
mom's voice she had a burned her tongue
that morning actually hope that's okay
with you it makes sense
yeah well make fun of her Walter so so
then the coffee was late too hot okay so
so then she made me go back to their
house immediately
I've knocked on the door and say that I
was sorry for taking it and you were
never invited again well no I I don't
even think I can we moved away after
that I still look like Oh Dan your mom
was so embarrassed I never stole [ __ ]
anything again in my life after that
[ __ ] dawg okay but I still a
kaleidoscope from a store I remember I
was three years old and I knew I knew it
was wrong but I knew if I got caught I
could pretend out I was dumb because I
knew that as a as three years old I was
innocent
yeah I'd be like I didn't know you
wonder why your kids like your brother
better and I totally believed it
true by weight these young guys baby
pepper that was the first time I stole
anything trouble I didn't get in trouble
cuz I played dumb and they just made me
return to the stores like I didn't know
I couldn't take and I played with it in
front of them because I would got caught
I mean I didn't get caught and it was
too easy like I thought my mom was gonna
know right away and we like went the
whole day around the shopping mall and
then we went back to the car and I just
started playing with it like I guess
it's fun and they didn't say anything
and then she said where'd you get that
and I was like store we didn't pay for
that I was like oh it looks cool
it doesn't suck at all actually and then
she made me return it and I didn't get
in trouble jack my neighbor's car sign I
didn't get in trouble I reject your
neighbors car sound what's that I mean
like back in like when you're younger I
think was like a Asian thing that steal
car signs it was cool to have like a
bunch of like all the emblem so I just
went up and down the street and I just
stole everyone's car sign Wow anything
good like the Jaguar one no I found out
that the American ones were really hard
to steal like Rick Ford it doesn't just
pop off like like the Honda ones do and
I was like I got a screwdriver mouth
really dry he was three years old give
me a break three years old with this
groceries Longy guy
[Music]